For the first time in decades, Virginia bars
and restaurants can finally advertise happy hour.
It's the latest in a number of recent victories
that make it easier to enjoy your favorite drink.
In 2019 we also saw the repeal of a law that
banned distilling spirits on Native American lands
and a supreme court decision that could open
up alcohol sales across state lines.
The recent reforms we've seen in places like
Virginia with their happy hour law may seem small
but they are slowly pointing us towards a
better boozy future.
We asked R Street's resident alcohol law expert
Jarret Dieterle
about some of the most nonsensical alcohol
laws.
There's still a lot of dumb alcohol laws on
the books today and here's five examples of them.
In North Carolina good luck getting a cheap
drink with buddies after work.
North Carolina doesn't have happy hour at
all.
I like to call them sad hours.
You can get food specials, you can get discounts
on that,
but you can't get drink specials which is
what everyone associates happy hour with.
They also have other weird restrictions like
buying your buddies a round.
If you buy a pitcher of beer for example,
anything that has more than one serving of alcohol,
two people have to go to the bar and pay for it,
one person can't just pay it and bring it back to the table.
So it's pretty a fairly depressing place in
North Carolina when it comes five o clock
and you want to head to the bar.
And then there's Utah's Zion Curtain.
It requires bar tenders basically to stand
behind a partition or a wall
when they're mixing cocktails.
The Utah legislature tried to reform it and
they ended up making it even more complicated.
The justification for the law is they don't
want the children or people that are sensitive I guess
to see cocktails and hard alcohols being mixed
together.
Every other state of course you can go into
and watch a bartender actually mixing a drink
and it's completely fine and normal and hurts
no one.
And in Louisiana you can't have airplane sized
liquor bottles.
Louisiana currently allows 100 milliliter
bottles
which are twice the size of the normal airplane bottles
but they still arbitrarily draw a limit on
the regular 50 milliliter size ones that we want.
I think the theory for it originally is that
little liquor bottles are easier for people to conceal.
That might allow people that have an addiction
issue to over indulge more
if they have a small concealable bottle.
Of course lots of states have done the opposite
and thought that less amounts of alcohol
is probably better for people that have an addiction problem.
In Indiana, good luck picking up a cold six
pack.
Their gas stations cannot sell refrigerated
beer, they have to leave it at room temperature
and it has to be warm.
You know, if your'e going in, filling up your
tank of gas,
and want to grab a chilled twelve pack you
can't do it.
Which makes summer barbecues particularly
depressing I'm sure.
The market's actually responded in a fairly
clever way
although they probably shouldn't have to
but some of the, you'll see in gas stations
in Indiana now
is like chiller bags that they'll fill with ice.
Apparently they claim to, you know, chill
the beer in 15 minutes or really quickly.
But again you have to ask yourself why we
created an arbitrary barrier
that forces something like that to even be
necessary
whereas it isn't in other states.
And finally, in some states,
government stores
are the only place to get your favorite bottle of bourbon.
Some places like Virginia ABC stores,
you actually have to go to a retail store
run by the government of Virginia
to be able to buy your alcohol.
People should care because it limits their
choices,
and it also hurts producers that are trying
to create innovative products.
So despite all the progress that's been made
in eliminating stupid liquor laws,
the rules governing the sector are still often
random and absurd.
So let's raise a glass to the ongoing fight
to liberalizing alcohol sales.
Because open markets mean colder, cheaper
and more abundant booze.